there is one more thing the iconic line
repeated yet again on the day Apple
revealed the iPhone 8 and deep down I
knew something big was coming Apple
revealing not one but two iPhones at a
single event was the peak of marketing
at the time bringing to us the all-new
iPhone x amidst all the hype there was
one question that shot through my mind
at the time where did iPhone 9 go join
me as I investigate Apple's history of
why they decided to skip the iPhone 9.
let me dispel a misconception before we
head in let me clear a common
misconception Apple did not skip the
iPhone 9 due to Superstition if that
were the case then they wouldn't have
released the iPhone 13 either which has
been selling like hotcakes but let's be
honest nine isn't such an attractive
number to begin with but was that why
Apple skipped it everything that Apple
has ever done has significantly impacted
its sales and it'd be hard to believe if
that wasn't the case here as well so I
spent the last few days studying how
Apple has maintained its growth as a
company and the strategies that have
guided every step they've taken so that
I could put out this video for you a bit
of History first let me take you to 2005
when Steve Jobs revealed the first iPod
Nano from his jeans pocket a Sleek
device that slips right into our mini
pocket now we know
because this
is the new
iPod
[Music]
those tiny Pockets weren't of much use
until that point but Steve Jobs the
legend turned them into excellent
marketing material fast forward to 2007
when the first iPhone was revealed an
iPod a phone and an internet
Communicator an iPod
a phone
and an internet communicator
an iPod
a phone
are you getting it as repeated by Steve
Jobs was the beginning of the era of
iPhones or smartphones for that matter
apple is known for breaking the
traditional Norms from the beginning and
if we take a look at the iPhones to date
they have consistently named their
iPhones numerically up until iPhone x
was revealed but here's the twist Apple
wanted us to call it the iPhone 10
instead of x if that was the case why
did they name it X I asked the same
question when they named their digital
media player Apple TV when it was
basically just another digital media
player Apple wanted their customers to
feel as if they were purchasing an
individual product that sounded much
cooler and not just something that
helped us connect to our TV and it's not
just the Apple TV in fact every one of
their products was named smartly to give
it the Branded touch like the apple
pencil the iPod the iMac and lastly the
MacBook series better known as just max
when these were first released I was
confused about how a computer had
anything to do with a Mac which until
then conjured an image of a burger in my
mind but no more after after Apple
showed up and as much as it confused me
it intrigued me further into wanting to
get that product that stood out from the
rest and that's precisely what they did
with the iPhone 10. Apple made a very
bold move to show the world that it was
bringing an unusual phone why did they
skip the iPhone 9 now that you
understand why Apple names their
products a bit differently it makes it
easier for me to explain why they
skipped the number nine 2017 will remain
a significant year for Apple for two
reasons first off it was the 10-year
anniversary of the first iPhone launch I
hope you're getting where I'm going with
this secondly the iPhone x was a massive
upgrade from the previous version and
beat all other manufacturers not just in
terms of Technology but in terms of
pricing as well of course nothing new
from Apple but it was the first time
that an iPhone was priced at one
thousand dollars at release the iPhone
10's release bypassing the expected
iPhone 9 was a bold statement it was a
statement that this new iPhone wasn't
just your routine update coming around
each year but a significant upgrade to
the best tech you could get your hands
on at the time it was up to Apple to
ensure that people understood that the
2017 iPhone's release was significant
that is why they jumped right over the
expected iPhone 9 and even went the
extra mile to use a Roman numeral for
their product setting it aside from the
standard iPhones because they would be
mispronounced as X instead of the number
10 and there was an additional layer of
confusion on top of this because Apple
had always released their iPhones in
numerical order from the iPhone 4 to the
iPhone 7 and iPhone 8 and out of nowhere
an iPhone model came with a letter
rather than a number I called it iPhone
x right off the bat and that's how Apple
succeeded in clearly putting it out
there that the new iPhone was nothing
like its previous versions be it X or 10
it symbolizes the 10-year anniversary of
the iPhone and they boldly stated that
it was a significant upgrade would it
have been half as successful if the new
iPhone model had been named the iPhone 9
instead of X and there you have it
that's the Brilliance of marketing and
that's how Apple made people worldwide
believe they were getting something
really good as I started to dig deeper
are into this I found that most people
still expected Apple to bring in the
iPhone 9 even after the release of the
iPhone 10 and 11. the News was out in
the open that a new budget iPhone that
was supposed to be released in 2020
might be that missing model while some
people thought it was going to be the
new iPhone SE some still had their hopes
that it would be called the iPhone 9.
there were a fair few reasons why people
thought it could be named the next
iPhone SE because it was around the same
price point as the original SE model of
2016 at 400 and that's precisely what
Apple released many people were
surprised that iPhone named it iPhone SE
instead of filling the Gap they had left
out in the iPhone series by directly
jumping to iPhone 10. well it was an
excellent opportunity for Apple to even
the Gap right but if you've listened
closely till now you'd have understood
why Apple didn't go after the iPhone 9.
Apple doesn't confine its product naming
to logical reasoning or the norm but
instead they give significance to
products that bring more value to the
table and effectively Market them
because in the end that's what sets
their product products apart from the
crowd now imagine if Apple actually
named their 2020 budget phone iPhone 9
to fill the Gap Creator three years back
it directly suggests that the model was
released between the iPhone 8 and the
iPhone 9 which through the iPhone 9
three years back making it look old and
unattractive to its customers not to
mention Apple names their premium phones
with numbers whereas a 400 budget phone
cannot be considered premium naming the
new budget iPhone as iPhone 9 would have
set the wrong expectation for the
product and dampened the marketing
effect instead the SE appeals to a
completely different Market than the
iPhone 10 11 or 12 that came out
afterward now if you're someone like me
who is still not over the fact that they
skipped the iPhone 9 I hate to break it
to you but the number nine was not the
only number that Apple skipped right
after the original iPhone there were the
iPhone 3G and the 3Gs to make it even
worse the 3G name was based on the 3G
network that the phone operated on and
not the actual number three and just
because Apple couldn't fill in the
iPhone 2 it did didn't ever go back to
make an iPhone 2 through all these years
and technically Apple only started
numerically naming their phones from
iPhone 4 onwards in the end they're just
numbers and apple sure does know how to
Market those and they'll keep going
against the grain if they see marketing
benefit in naming a specific iPhone
model differently but what do you think
about this entire iPhone 9 debate and
what do you think was the best marketing
trick Apple has pulled off over the
years let me know in the comments below
and if you enjoyed this video you might
want to watch the next one that is on
the screen right now until next time